I know you're on the Homeland Security
Committee yeah it's a horrible attack
again this week in Brussels I know what
Trump's message is it's a horrible
message I don't agree with it I don't
know what the Democrat message is
democratic message is on this what what
what is it well so first of all I you
know I'm not I don't want to think about
one of the great threats to our country
through a political lens I want to think
about what's the American message in all
of this and how are we going to defeat
what we see is a determined enemy that
is doing horrific things not just the
United States not just to Europe I know
we got all we will get a lot of
attention on things that happened this
week but just today there were were
people killed in Iraq at a soccer game
can't even go to a soccer game in fact
Isis has been killing more Muslims and
they've been killing anyone else and so
our response has got to be what we're
doing right now which is taking their
territory away from them this ideal they
have this perverse ideal that they have
of creating a caliphate we're going to
take their land back and we're going to
win or in that field but we also have to
disrupt their terrorist networks and we
have to counter violent extremism at
home and so that's not a soundbite but
Saint wait you say violent extremism
I've said this before on this show I
think the Democrats risk losing this
election if they cannot put together the
words if extremism as opposed to violent
extremism please just tell me that you
recognize that is a distinct threat much
greater than any other violent extremist
threat you don't really think it's on
the same order as the KKK well first of
all are you really worried about the KKK
well what I'm worried about is that you
began that question by saying the
Democrats will lose if first of all the
Democrats lose because of how they talk
about this extremism then they've got
more problems my party writer that's
their biggest well maybe that's what
we'll lose the Yola if there's a
terrorist attack what if this was LAX
instead of the Brussels Airport
I mean 45% of Democrats already if you
take Trump's name off his proposal to
ban Muslims coming into this country
agree with it Democrats and so look this
is a threat like no other and it's ones
that literally keeps me up like no
working on like no other but I
also understand and I'm not I'm not
creating a false equivalency here but
since 9/11 we've lost 48 Americans
Boston bombing uh and we've and to the
Christian walking in to Planned
Parenthood colorado
mascar massacring people but people
watch these are not trying to get it
entered in about and i'm not they're not
that is not false accrued I'm not trying
I'm saying I'm not trying to create the
false equivalency I'm saying that when
you say to me that this is the only
threat we should be taught that we will
I'm saying only no no that we were
saying it's distinct right and different
and bigger until size matter what I'm
saying to you is that and what I'm
saying to you is I I am as a senator
spending an x-coordinate amount of time
focusing on that but what frustrates me
is here you and I are having a
conversation when we pivoted off of
Newark but I've got kids with lead
poisoning in the water in Newark I've
got a poverty that's even working
full-time job for an issue we got it and
I work at the same and so what I'm
saying to you is that I think what
Americans are Americans are hungry for
is a vision in which we can manifest our
strengths as a country by focusing on
the whole panoply of issues and if we
okay and I err is important it's in
April and and and and all your mongering
is is weakening - it's not mongering if
there's an attack I mean yes of course
Trump is fear-mongering
right I think and Cruz trying to open
this week on patrol Muslim neighborhoods
it's why can't be disgusting so why do
we play that level where this is about a
two-minute soundbite as opposed to a
sophisticated plan to defeat our enemy
not only abroad but the enemy when it
manifests itself here at home just say
Islamic terrorism I want to say those
words and you'll win the election Boyd
those words and you're gonna lose the
election that's my advice and I hear you
I know you're not running but I've gotta
say they've right now I've heard you
mentioned as a VP candidate as a Supreme
Court nominee the next James Bond
and you know they need a new most
interesting man in the world so thank
you very much to me in Hungary your job